allez on prend la direction de sellette
et son château de Beauregard un édifice
connu pour ses 327 portraits qui sont
accrochés et le représentent 15 règnes
de Philippe 6 à Louis XII 36 ans
maintenant et qu'ils étaient en
restauration la voilà qui touche à sa
fin vous voyez ce reportage d'Hélène
chapelet
dans l'histoire du château de Beauregard
le 28 juin 2023 est une nouvelle date
clé elle marque la fin de la
restauration des 327 portraits de la
galerie des illustres 37 ans que le
chantier lancé alors pour la dernière
fois ce mercredi les 12 photos encore
restantes ont été retirées pour que les
vrais oeuvres puissent réintégrer leur
place sur le mur un ensemble classé et
qui a traversé quatre siècles grâce à
l'investissement de ces différents
propriétaires successifs
mes parents ont commencé en 86 ma mère a
continué ensuite et puis j'ai repris
avec ma femme il y a une dizaine
d'années et voilà donc on a enfin bouclé
cette restauration c'est c'est à la fois
quelque chose de un soulagement c'est
aussi
quelque chose qui a c'est le travail
d'une vie
c'est incroyable galerie de portrait
c'est un peu le gratin dénotable du
passé on y retrouve tous les grands
hommes et 21 femmes qui ont marqué
l'histoire de France entre 1300 et 1600
un ensemble inédit composé de tableaux
peints entre 1617 et 1638
c'est une des seules galeries de
portraits de grands hommes du XVIIe
siècle encore en place en fait on peut
se mettre ici dans la galerie et passer
des jours et des jours à regarder chaque
personnage et à réfléchir sur
quel a été l'importance de ce personnage
dans l'histoire et qu'est-ce qui nous
raconte pour nous aujourd'hui donc c'est
vraiment un livre d'histoire pour
découvrir cet ensemble unique direction
sellette et le château de Beauregard le
site est ouvert tous les jours de
juillet d'août de 10 heures à 18h30